this video is proudly sponsored by
Squarespace stick around until the end
of the video to learn about a deal
they're making available through my
channel
chaos is the biggest factor missing from
many people's training what do I mean by
chaos essentially I mean variety or as
Nikolai Bernstein put it repetition
without repetition without this your
strength and fitness may very well be
just for show we are taught the
importance of maintaining proper form
and of repeating movements over and over
again in order to refine them and
strengthen the underlying neural
Pathways we are taught the importance of
specificity and choosing exercises that
perfectly match what we're training for
if you want to learn how to front lever
the general advice is that you need to
practice with your arms with the correct
distance apart on a straight bar with
perfect form over and over again as
Bruce Lee said I fear not the man who's
practiced 10 000 kicks once but I fear
the man who's practiced one kick ten
thousand times
but this is only useful up to a point
because if you always train under
perfect conditions you'll only perform
at your best when you're in those
perfect conditions this is the true
implication of specificity and it's
crucial to understand when it comes to
the transferability of skill in other
words it's one thing to be able to score
a goal during practice but it's quite
another to score that same goal when
you're already tired it's muddy and
someone is barging into you from behind
recently I've been working a lot on
handstands and handstand push-ups as I
do a lot of my training outside though
is sometimes more challenging doing
handstands on grass is nice because you
have a soft Landing but also means the
ground is rarely flat one hand is often
higher than the other or I might be on a
slight decline this massively changes
the activation of the muscles and the
amount of information I have to contend
with progresses slower as a result But
ultimately it means that I'm learning to
do handstands anywhere and that's much
cooler right
in a similar manner doing pull-ups and
chin-ups from a tree branch means
dealing with the hands at different
heights varying widths of the branch
slippery patches and much more this
makes it much more applicable to actual
climbing Nikolai Bernstein is best known
for his work on the degrees of freedom
problem this refers to the seemingly
endless number of ways the body can
carry out any given task how does the
nervous system choose the precise angle
of the shoulder joint shape of the hand
flexion of the elbow when doing
something as simple as picking up a mug
of tea the truth is that every movement
is slightly different every single time
even the simple ones your starting
position will be slightly different
every time your relative fatigue the
speed of movement and any momentum
with this in mind it becomes crucial
that we train in a way to reflect this
if functional performance is our end
goal this is what we call repetition
without repetition or variable practice
and also known as variable training
some ways we can accomplish this include
practicing with a variety of tools
things like kettlebells and sandbags
utilize offset and even shifting centers
of gravity ensuring that no two lifts
are ever quite the same practicing out
of sequence this is called contextual
interference and has been shown in
several studies to result in better
performance as compared with block
practice where you perform batches of
the same movement over and over almost
all traditional gym routines emphasize
block practice so this can be a
fantastic way to start actually applying
your newfound strength and Mobility I'll
share the studies backing this up below
or you can go to the article
accompanying this video
worrying a little bit less about form is
also a good idea perfect form is great
for competition but for the real world
training with your shoulders wider one
day and narrower than next is actually
beneficial as long as you're not putting
your body in any seriously compromised
positions you're just preparing yourself
to be able to do the same movement from
that slightly less optimal angle
and training outdoors and in variable
conditions is great as mentioned varied
terrain and randomly shaped objects
found Outdoors offer inbuilt variability
and this is the problem our bodies are
built for the natural chaos that comes
from training and moving outside not
from the clinical and linear world that
we've built for ourselves
what I'm not advocating for here is just
randomly training with no consistency
form or measurement especially for
beginners getting the basics down with
solid repetitions in a controlled
environment is Paramount but as you
start to master these Basics instead of
just adding weight why not incorporate a
little variety and Chaos as Nikolai
Bernstein explains you'll build far more
robust movement patterns the neural
Pathways will have more variability and
more options
this variability this noise is not a bug
but an important feature of optimal
human movement
I think that the person we should truly
fear then is the one who practices one
kick ten thousand different ways
to be clear if you're just interested in
building bigger biceps or getting a
bigger squat then training with regular
exercises sets and Reps at the gym will
be absolutely fine but if you want to go
from being someone who's good at
exercise to a good athlete or a good
mover then using variable training is
absolutely key and may take you to that
next level by stress testing your
Fitness and performance and as we've
seen there's lots of ways we can do this
whether it just means taking your
training outside of the gym and into a
more variable environment whether it
means slightly tweaking the technique
each time or training out of sequence
like we see in movement flows and the
like or something else you can do if you
have more of a passing interest in this
stuff is to just combine your training
with some kind of hobby or sport if on
top of going to the gym you also cycle
rock climb play football do martial arts
then you're going to be again stress
testing that Fitness and introducing
more variable positions more
unpredictable scenarios the jam
specificity has become so popular that
it's actually entered the mainstream
lexicon even if you're not into
functional trade training many people
will understand what specificity and
training means I think that we should
treat variable training with the same
reverence because it is just as
important and the two concepts go hand
in hand because if you're training with
perfect specificity for non-specific
activities that just doesn't really make
any sense does it and if you're looking
for a training program that develops
functional performance and incorporates
variable training as a key element then
look no further than super functional
training 2.0 that's my training program
with over two hours of instructional
video and an 85 Plus page ebook
and if you want more on this topic then
check out my recent print book adaptive
training I'll link to both of them in
the description down below what do you
guys think how do you include
variability in your own training thanks
a ton for watching guys and bye for the
time being
variability
now just let me take a moment to talk to
you about today's sponsor Squarespace
Squarespace is a website building
platform that just happens to be one of
the most versatile tools on the web
Squarespace makes building a website
extremely easy thanks to its drag and
drop functionality that requires zero
coding knowledge at the same time though
it has all the features you could
possibly need and then some to build any
site you can imagine more than enough to
power some of the biggest brands in the
world
Squarespace comes with Advanced
publishing tools that offer content
creation formatting scheduling for posts
and more you can build a community with
member management and fully integrated
commenting System including threaded
comments replies and likes or why not
integrate your social media accounts for
a stream of additional content
site owners can generate income with
members only gated content or a slew of
powerful e-commerce features that let
them sell products directly from their
site and it's possible to add even more
features to your Squarespace website by
using the huge number of available
plugins for example you can extend your
e-commerce functionality with inventory
management global Shipping tax
reconciliation and more
building a website is something I think
everyone should try it can legitimately
change your life Squarespace is the
easiest way to get started in minutes
literally minutes so give it a try head
over to squarespace.com to learn more
and when you're ready go to
squarespace.com here to get 10 off your
first domain or website thanks again
massively to Squarespace for sponsoring
this video
and bye for now